good morning Hank it's Monday please to
be ignoring the decapitated parrot in
the background today's video comes to
you in four parts part 1 my encounter
with Greg Mortenson so hank greg
mortenson the author of three cups of
tea has been much in the news lately
there are accusations that he fabricated
part of his memoir and that his charity
doesn't run as efficiently as it should
I think it so happens that I can
contribute to that conversation because
I have met Greg Mortenson and I thought
I would tell you the story of how that
went okay so a couple years ago when
Paper Towns came out I went to a library
convention and Penguin my publisher
through this author dinner for like
eight authors with 200 or something
young adult librarians important note
almost all young adult librarians are
ladies okay back to the story right so
at this author dinner I was one of the
authors and so was Greg Mortenson and we
each had our own table that was full of
librarians and we ate dinner and drank
wine and chatted and then we had to give
like a two-minute presentation and I was
like oh I wrote this book it's about
Walt Whitman and imagining other people
complexly I hope you like it i sat down
and then right after me greg mortenson
got up and he was like that book sounds
interesting my book is about how I
almost died and decided to devote my
life to education in Afghanistan and I'm
sitting at my table kind of drunk
thinking oh I wrote a book with a bunch
of PG oaks in it and this guy is out
saving the world but then I remember
that nerdfighters helped rebuild a
school in cyclone ravaged Bangladesh and
I wanted to tell him about it but he was
all the way across this huge room I
could barely even see the guy so I got
the bright idea to go talk to him during
the cocktail party portion of the
program that followed the dinner so as
soon as we're finished eating I race up
to Greg Mortenson and I say I was so
great to hear your speech I loved your
book which I hadn't read and Hank as you
well know in this equation x equals not
being able to shut up so I start talking
to Greg Mortenson about this online
community nerdfighters and all the cool
stuff that we're doing we're building
ponds and filters in Bangladesh
we're doing Kiva micro loans we built
this school it's so awesome and I buy
him a drink the drinks were free but
still and at some point I realized that
I've been talking to Greg Mortenson for
12 minutes and I have not allowed him to
say a single word so I say I'm sorry to
go on so much I'm just a huge fan of
your work and then he says thank you but
I'm not Greg Mortenson
oh because 95% of young adult librarians
are women I just walked up to the white
guy figuring that that would be Greg
Mortenson and it wasn't oh the
humiliation is still washing over me
Hank so hey here's what I have to add to
the Greg Mortenson discussion it seems
like his heart is in the right place
although that doesn't always matter and
he looks like a lot of other white guys
part two are you Dutch not you Hank I
know you're not Dutch but the other
people they might be if you are Dutch
please read the video info below there
is relevant information for you part
three Hank oh 2-mile Hank your birthday
is coming up it's Hank Oh DeMayo
May fifth sewing - turning 31 usually we
do something really nice for you and
your birthday except when we forget but
this year your birthday is very
inconvenient leave located for me
because I am desperately trying to
finish this book so I have decided to
outsource your birthday to nerdfighteria
nerdfighters you will find a link in the
doobly-doo to a birthday thread in your
pants where we can discuss ways to make
Hanks birthday awesome Hank don't read
it or I will gouge out your eyes
probably not that's probably excessive
but don't read it and lastly part 4 I'm
gonna do a question Tuesday on Friday
things that don't make sense to new
viewers so please leave your questions
in comments Hank don't forget to be
awesome I will see you on Wednesday